it's a huge pleasure to welcome the
newest procurement Minister James
castles very welcome indeed sir to our
proceedings here today along with air
Chief Marshall Sir Richard Knighton uh
newly head of uh appointed as head of
the uh the arm of the RAF uh vice
admiral Richard Thompson his director
General Air D and S thanks very much
indeed for your time uh this afternoon
um if we may before we go into our
Aviation procurement this will be the
last of our studies that we're doing we
did a big study as you know on the Army
we did another on the Navy and this will
conclude our look at Aviation and of
course we're waiting for the uh
integrated review refresh the Defense
command paper to arrive so that if I may
it's just a couple of quick questions to
begin with before we get into the
substantive
firstly is there any indication do we
have a date as to when that document the
Defense command paper of the integrated
review refresh will be published
um the aim is by the end of June end of
June okay we look forward to that
secondly what came up in defense
questions on Monday was that there were
problems with the propulsion system of
HMS Prince of Wales
um
clearly was a very very technical aspect
to do with the the propeller shaft are
you able to give a clarity as to how
long it will take for the repairs to be
made when will it be back at Sea and
secondly what impact will this have on
the other aircraft carrier so um well
can I just briefly say it's a great
pleasure to be here and an honor to
attend for the first time and to hold
this brief and I look forward to
engaging closely with you I would I
think just on a sort of point of order
we've my team will be in touch with Mr
Francois and the Clarks about the
subcommittee appointment today about the
further investigation
um but on this point I think that
spiritual the Secretary of State said
this but it's certainly the case that
our aim is that the Prince of Wales will
return as planned as was originally
planned this Autumn and that will
include flying trials so that was the
original plan she'd been anticipated to
be as I say alongside the march of 2023
so obviously there's considerable
attention in this but to that extent on
on schedule from an operational point of
view okay and there was a cast I think
incurred in this the tune of 25 million
pounds I understand who pay for the
repair our decision has not been made
yet I'm afraid something we are
considering I I think you've had a
letter on this from my predecessor again
it didn't clarify exactly I think there
were it's it's obviously to do with the
legal contract I suppose as to then who
is actually responsible for this given
that it was done before it went to sea
and therefore before the actual Handover
so so contractual issue perhaps to do
the subcontractor as well
um I I wouldn't want to go into any
commercial confidentialities other than
to say we are considering basically our
options on this
um but you're right that there is a 25
million pound cost good thank you very
much my final question is just to do
with the role of China in our
procurement processes is it the the the
the the the the wish or indeed the the
the determination of the mod to weed out
any Chinese influence in our procurement
processes is that the new positioning
given where we are on critical National
infrastructure of removing China's
influence I mean as you know Mr chairman
there is a huge amount of work across
government on this point we have the new
legislation I in fact have attended
recently the cross-government committee
in respect of National Security issues
obviously it's all classified but
um certainly we we have taken I believe
an internal review recently of
um our own use of uh in terms of
uh the phrase which briefly escapes me
about vendors sorry my apologies about
vendors of concern from a mod point of
view I can't obviously go into any
detail on that but it's something we are
very much uh focused on
um that's absolutely right I think it's
good to hear that it's also important to
recognize this is what China does very
subtly and buying up companies buying up
influence it's doing that with ports
across the world
but I understand that the China
international Maritime containers group
also owns a number of companies
including Albert Ziegler gmbh is based
in Germany they own Visa BV group that
are based in Netherlands and they
produce the boxer which we are now
purchasing
um could I leave it with you to find out
whether any of the boxes we're procuring
we're building actually have our own
have any connection with China through
this ownership of company
yeah I would have to look into that and
right back to committee that's very very
kind indeed with that all done let's
move on to Aviation
um uh procurement and Sarah can you kick
us off please thank you chair and
congratulations and welcome Minister on
a new post now James you've only had a
few weeks to get your feet under the
table but what has pleasantly surprised
you we can feel your remix of Defense
procurement
well um thank you very much and it's a
pleasure to obviously engage with you
and and your colleagues their first time
um I think if I were to say that there's
been much already in that short period
of time is it a short period of time
these days
um I think the key thing which I I think
I referred to in orals in response to Mr
Dugan was last week I had a great
privilege to visit operation interflex
on Salisbury Plain and see where we are
training ukrainians these are civilians
I there was a Management Consultant
there were two students they were all
people from normal walks of life who
within weeks will be back out in trench
warfare and they're being trained by the
British army alongside when I was there
the new zealanders and the Australians
and I'm incredibly proud of that but I
would say a key point is that they're
all going out with equipment that is of
the highest quality which we are
providing very effectively obviously
it's being done over a very short time
frame fantastic work
down at Abbey Wood but I think we should
be very proud of that because ultimately
procurement is about getting you know in
the in this kind of War setting is
getting people out there with the best
possible kit unfortunately in these very
short time frames but I do think we're
doing work to be proud of
so heading down to it the 2021 Defense
command paper reduced to the aircraft
numbers across all domains quite
significantly now you say the refresh is
coming at the end of June are we likely
to see or have you had any discussions
around
revising those numbers or gaining that
air capability for elsewhere well I I a
very good question and I totally
understand huge there will be huge focus
on this you know probably what I'm going
to say which is this is very much a live
piece of work we are doing I can't
prejudge it but very much when the DCP
comes out and say our Target is towards
the end of June clearly these are the
sorts of issues that we'll have to
consider
Okay so we've received evidence that's
been quite critical of the mod's
acceptance of capability gaps now the
Puma is due to retire in 2025 and yet d
e and s are quite frustrated uh with the
lack of performance process with a
medium-lift helicopter it's been pushed
back three or possibly four times to my
knowledge and I understand it's now
start to be signed off with the
assessment committee and that is that
needs to be signed off before it goes to
ITN which then could take a further six
months for that process to go through so
we were told earlier this committee were
told earlier that we would have the
winning bidder by Autumn now this is an
emerging capability Gap and my question
to you is do can you see what's going on
here and what are you doing and what's
the process the medium lift helicopter
procurement
again it's a very important question I
it's not for me to say what was she said
to you by people at DNS that's certainly
not a view that's been expressed to me
by them and obviously we work very
closely what I would say is as you know
last may we issued the contract notice
and the dynamic pqq
to invite expressions of interest and to
enable us to draw up a short list of
credible contenders who were then
invited to come forward and were
notified last October whether they were
on that shortlist I'm afraid beyond that
it is now obviously a life tender and
commercially confidential
it's a scope to
to the lifespan of the Puma
okay I can pick that up so the Puma was
originally going to be retired uh sooner
than 2025 in in the integrated review it
was extended in order to fulfill roles
in Cyprus and in Brunei it could be
extended uh still further out to 27 2028
that kind of time frame but that
decision's not been taken yet and that I
think will be dependent upon the the
progress of the new medium helicopter
competition but also the options to
replace uh puma in Cyprus and in Brunei
it's an army-led program it's an
army-led procurement so I'm not as close
to the detail but but as I say the work
there is it is feasible to extend Puma
if that were necessary but that decision
hasn't been taken and it'll be dependent
on those other factors okay thanks both
yeah thanks um are those Pumas the Pumas
that the United Kingdom bought off South
Africa
the remaining 23 Puma camps are they the
ones that we got the ones that were
upgraded uh about a decade or so ago
several of them have been retired I
actually know the the precise number
that we've got flying today I I think it
well certainly new medium left was
supposed to replace 23 Pumas six still
fans and six uh Bales three of each type
but the problem uh minister is that nmh
seems to be seems to be afflicted by a
habit that defense procurement in the
United Kingdom finds difficult to break
which is keeping industry in the dark
and then expecting them to deliver
overnight
and also kicking the can down the road
and inviting what has turned Loosely as
a capability Gap but what is actually a
profound capability risk into the
operation of our Armed Forces now one of
the things that really concerns me and I
know for a fact that it concerns
industry is that new medium lift was
listed in the mod's acquisition Pipeline
and then wasn't listed so delisted from
the mod's acquisition Pipeline and that
sends a really difficult signal to
Industry
when they see that sort of flaky
flip-flopping about you know do we need
it do we not need it of course with nmh
of course we need it but when do we need
it when do we invest in training skills
improvements materials the subcontract
supply chain it doesn't speak to an
integrated approach to these projects
between defense and Industry and that's
a space that amod has occupied for a
long time and we need to get out of it
so how do we get out of it and what is
happening within image well it's a it's
a it's a perfectly fair question I don't
agree that we are flip-flop
flip-flopping by following what is
effectively a standard tendering process
um and uh and and I think the key thing
I said about we'd issued the contract
notice uh response is evaluated
determine a short list of credible
suppliers who were then notified so
they're not kept in the dark the
commercial actors in This have been
notified
um there is uh the one other thing I
could say there is a lot of complexity
in this we need to establish the
parameters of the competition
and this is not something that we have
dropped as you implied
um we're committed to it but yeah so we
are considering this but I cannot say
more than that for commercials
confidentiality reasons
Minister welcome to your new post we
genuinely hope you'll be in it for a
while
the history of this program if you
pardon the awful pun is that it's been
going around in circles for years I mean
it it was kicked off about six or seven
procurement ministers ago
so can you can you tell us two things
when do you expect to award a contract
to whoever it is and what is the initial
operating capability date for that
helicopter when is it designed to come
into service what are the two dates
please
we haven't determined those those
answers Mr Francois that where we're at
is we are working out the parameters for
the competition itself obviously we have
the requirements we then have to have
the competition
um that will then inform points around
the the dates that follow on from that
in the usual way with respect minister
if you don't even know when it's
supposed to come into service you
haven't really got a proper competition
yet the the criticism on this particular
program is it has gone round and round
in circles with very little definition
very few Hard dates of any kind and
today in front of the committee you
still can't tell us when it's going to
enter service do you understand the
point that this has been highly
criticized it's a very vague program no
I understand I mean you've been in this
position you know you'll have no I never
did the procurement job obviously but
you've been a sorry a defense minister
um there is and it's something I'm
having to get used to very quickly there
is a lot of potential information but
there's a relatively limited amount you
can save because of confidentiality and
I I say that in all sincerity
um I've given you as much as I can with
what we feel is acceptable it is a live
stream we need we need we've got lots of
progress to make and we've got a lot of
other aircraft types there is a you're
actually stepping into this world that
we spend a lot of time looking at the
fact that the decision making is slow
these two the rotary systems exist
already they're not new inventions
people are waiting to be given the green
light I've sat in both of these aircraft
who cries somebody to make a decision
and that's really I think what the
message is coming loud and clear uh from
here
um can we move on to uh question number
two please before I do that can I just
say and we'll have the committee thank
you very much indeed we had a very uh
fruitful visit to Abbey Wood to DNS I
just want to put that on the record
um full day there and it was much
appreciated indeed so thank you very
much indeed uh Dave yeah thanks chair
what are the key lessons in terms of um
in terms of a Ukraine for the employment
of airport in Modern Warfare and
obviously there's been a period of a
couple of decades where it's been
possible for um the United Kingdom and
its allies to exercise air power in a
relatively or profoundly actually
uncontested uh way which is not to do
anything to diminish the quality and
standard of airmanship within within the
area for the air forces of their allies
but Ukraine is a different thing and so
what lessons have been learned from the
um 14 15 months of that I just get one
very general answer first because
clearly I want to hear from the uh
kazdetic
um so uh I think it's it's actually a
lesson which we've known since the
second world war which is the
overwhelming importance of air
superiority that if you don't achieve
that you can end up in
so is what you would call gridlocked
Warfare with trenches and so on
um so to me as a defense minister that
is an overall lesson and the follow-on
from that and it's something I will
probably say in pretty much all of my
answers is the importance of our
alliance and the deterrence and I'm
talking about not obviously the nuclear
Terran but the deterrent effect of being
in a powerful Alliance so that we don't
get into this situation in the first
place but ensuring that that Alliance is
strong and has in totality
um strong power but I will pass over to
we could spend the whole of the rest of
the guys talking about this and and we I
like we do need to be careful as we
think about the lessons from this that
we don't draw false lessons
um or necessarily jump to conclusions
and I've heard many many commentators
draw almost whatever lessons they might
like from it but as some of you have
heard me talk either at rusi or or in
other places there are three big
strategic lessons I draw from what we're
seeing in Ukraine and a number of more
sort of tactical and operational that
I'll talk through quickly uh chair I
mean strategically the point is exactly
the one that the minister makes which is
fundamentally we do not want to get into
the kind of fight that we see in Ukraine
today that horribly attritional trench
warfare is is we thought a thing of the
past and part of the reason why that is
the way the campaign is unfolding is
because neither side has been able to
exercise our superiority
but it does give us a glimpse of the
challenges of gaining air superiority in
a fight in the future and we have to be
able to demonstrate that we can do that
and I expect that in the future we will
have to be more prepared than we have
been for the last 20 years to be able to
fight for control of the air and that
will probably be limited Limited in time
and limited in geography but without it
you can't deliver any kind of military
effect either from the air or or on the
ground will it not also be limited in
terms of aircraft from the United
Kingdom's point of view so I want to
give you my understanding of a F-35 and
its role and characterized as you send
that high-end absolute and Peerless or
certainly allegedly Peerless aircraft in
which then operates as the basically the
ringmaster which then controls the
aerial combat environment and sends in
fourth generation aircraft in Mass to do
the actual speed work of combat and
securing air superiority in combat yeah
that's fine if you have an ff35s I'd be
interested in your perspective oh I
don't want to go into that too much
somebody else is going to forget that
question
you got into the first point and then I
think there were two more points
I will pick up exactly but your
characterization of a combination of
fourth and fifth gen uh combat air
capability I think is exactly right and
that's exactly how we see it as we think
about it with our allies in NATO I mean
just to not to spoil the follow-on
question but uh General Hecker who's the
commander United States Air Force is
Europe and I were chatting a few weeks
ago and he said by the early 2030s there
will be 550 f-35s in Europe belonging to
Nato and less than 60 of them uh being
from the United States so that's the
kind of level of Cape not many being
used in Ukraine right now correct and
I'll no doubt you'll come back to that
so the first point is really about this
importance of deterrence and that
credible capability as the minister said
the second point is about the import is
is our superiority the third big
strategic lesson I draw from it is that
the the side that is able to adapt the
fastest is the side that will prevail
and what we're seeing with Russia's
hapless
operations in all domains but but
particularly in the air domain is an
absence of training but also an absence
of ability to adapt to the circumstances
in contrast Ukraine with help from their
Western allies our demonstration the
most remarkable ability to adapt
capability to exploit technology to
change their tactics and deliver a
remarkable effect against what was a a
much larger dominating Air Force in in
Russia so those are the big three
strategic lessons I mean tactically and
operationally clearly there's a lesson
here about stockpiles and the importance
of stockpiles and the industrial
capacity that sits alongside it we know
that electronic warfare has been a
critical enabler and a key Battleground
on both sides
in the conflict and our capability for
in terms of electronic warfare
definitely degraded in the early 2000s
with our focus on counter-insurgency but
is improving with with technology like
F-35
we're seeing increasing uses of uncrewed
systems and what that can do in terms of
delivering strategic effects as well as
delivering the ability to overwhelm
defenses and there's a fundamental point
about our ability to operate in an agile
fashion what Ukraine has been able to do
is move its assets around and Russia is
having to do the same because in the in
some of the recent work shows is that in
the future Battlefield it's going to be
very hard to hide so our ability to be
agile I don't know General deptula
talked to the committee about agile
combat employment those are really key
important tactical lessons for us that
have quite profound implications in
terms of training in terms of focus and
priorities for for equipment let's say I
could talk about this all day but I'll
give one supplementary uh chair I think
you want to did you want to raise
Estonia as well
um or do you want me to do that I can't
remember that again did you want to
raise Estonia as well but I think I
would raise the enemy because what it is
your first point was details and an
element of the terms is your enemy being
aware of exactly that which you can pull
together and generate in terms of a
force and so and period verses of the
United Kingdom will be fully aware of
the scant numbers of typhoon that are in
possession and serviceable so trans twos
and thieves
um and half about half an order of f-35s
which is in the process of being
supplemented with further
um aircraft but those in terms of
typhoon
um are spread across air policing duties
in NATO's Eastern flank uh constabulary
Rose in the British Isles so Dave we are
wondering a little bit into number three
there we see more sandwiches there oh
sorry sorry well in that case you want
to do that you can disregard that
supplementary term we can move we'll
strike that from the record yes
there we go okay I think uh with that in
mind Kevin do you want to pick that up
well I think he's left a couple of
sandwiches
Chief Marshall I mean the issue is about
Mass except to have enough enough
aircraft it's actually also about
another assets air refueling
intelligence suppression so absolutely
and also a more important thing make
sure it trains together to be able to
deliver that isn't that's the important
key thing
and you just mentioned about the F-35
I'll come on that in a minute but in
terms of the numbers that are going to
be in Europe
haven't we got to really as a nation
change our narrative a little bit and
say that
um
what we are going to do in any future
conflicts is our contribution towards
our NATO commitment
rather than actually give the impression
that frankly we're ever going to go up
against Nation on our own
I just say just I don't well I
sorry
um I'd like to think we don't give that
impression I mean
so
if we could just uh why don't we all
just check our phones for a second to
make sure that doesn't happen again
thanks very much
so please continue well it wasn't me
um yes I'd like to think that isn't the
impression we give I think from the
Prime Minister secretary all of us in
government the absolute importance of
Coalition working with Partners uh the
Secretary of State uh is is abroad today
on on this very Point
um we have NATO coming up we have yeah I
think the prime minister with the prime
minister of the Netherlands yesterday
talking about you know F-16 every aspect
of our defense is configured upon the
Coalition and NATO but of course we have
our own National capabilities well I
don't think as a nation that that
shouldn't be seen as the signal we send
um I I would completely agree with the
minister as you might expect
um but the if I the the integrated
review is refresh is really clear about
the importance of our alliances and
particularly the centrality of NATO and
certainly coming in uh as the next chief
of the air staff my focus in terms of of
international engagement will be
particularly on NATO and that'll be one
of the very first trips that I I make as
the chief is is to uh Supreme uh
headquarters Ally command and also to
Ramstein where the international
combined air operations center is
because how we work and train and fight
together as NATO is how we will deter
Russia I was out in Estonia uh in
February and saw the Germans and the
British
typhoon Force operating side by side in
the quick reaction alert sheds there
talking to the pilots who'd flown have
been scrambled earlier in the month and
intercepted Russian aircraft and brought
them back together so that kind of
and
statement and demonstration of
interoperability is important part of
demonstrating to our potential
adversaries that this is what is brings
us our strength is this ability the
argument's got to be surely though
except what the minister said about
statements but it's got to be seen as is
and the question really is are we
actually making a contribution to Nato
that they actually requires and that's
the that's the case isn't it
yeah and there's a process that that we
go through the NATO defense planning
process the ndpp and that's where we
establish uh what inputs there are and
from a combat air perspective the UK
um alongside the US has one of the most
capable
contributions into NATO of any of the
NATO allies are you satisfied a vice
monitoring term Urban District Marshall
in terms of the training aspect in terms
of joint jointry is that
um in terms of course I mean that is the
key difference isn't it between I mean
you can have numbers I mean China's got
a lot of numbers but trying to put an
air Wing together to suppress an area is
a very difficult thing not just in terms
of how you do it but actually the num
sorry not just the numbers but it's how
you actually do the deploy the various
assets isn't it you're absolutely right
so the ability to orchestrate the assets
that you have in order to deliver the
effects is really complex and really
high end I mean the the Pinnacle of that
is the red flag exercises uh that we see
out in the US and we see that with UK
USA and Allied Nations flying together
but increasingly we're also going to see
this kind of training being done
synthetically so I was at RF Woodington
last week and saw the guardian facility
there which is just fantastic
um what what you've got sorry forgive me
not Gladiator facility at Waddington and
what that enables us is to bring
together assets from Land CNA and
internationally to train and practice in
really high-end complex environments
that we simply can't replicate in the
real world because it would either
require too much airspace or we'd
actually give away our tactics and I
think that's going to be the way we get
that kind of training I've already
mentioned F-35 can I now turn to it how
many f-35s have we delivered to date and
what was expect time scale for
delivering transform we've got 30
delivered to dates we'll have 48 by the
end of 2025 and you'll know that we
committed the department and government
committed to
take us up to 74 and that includes
replacing the aircraft that was lost
last year and that the deliveries of the
of the additional the trash 2 if you if
you want to describe it like that will
be start before the end of the decade
and we'll be complete in the early part
of the 2030s
that's we'll have 74 correct is that it
all the f-35bs that's it that is it what
we've always said is that we would make
a judgment on whether we would buy more
of those in the middle of this decade
and some of that would depend on the
progress we've made let's be honest I
mean because I've been around this
subject for many years now we start up
148 aircraft again isn't this where a
better honest it just needs to be said
is if if 74 is what we need for our NATO
commitments because like you say it's
not just Britain it's other it's work
with others should we just say that
rather than keep going around this
nonsense so that we're going to get we
are going to get this magical 40 148
which we're never going to get to are we
so as I said this is a hassle for you
that frankly I don't think you need
the original plan was 138 if you go back
20 years that that was the number that
was used the decision was taken in in
2010 to reduce that significantly down
to to only 48 and to actually reduce the
number of squadrons and therefore a
number of Pilots associated with it but
as I've said before it is still
plausible you can get to one through
eight but it depends on the decisions
that we make associated with I know how
about winning the lottery tonight but
you know it's an aspiration isn't it
okay I think the problem is is the the
issue that I have you see again it comes
back to the issues around our proposal
which the minister said about we are
going to work with our lives
I mean the aircraft carriers for me for
example I have no problem with them
deploying with the US and UK assets on
board that's I think a force multiplier
that we should be proud of and actually
work with
I just think that we need to get in
honesty we're not going to get up to
above
the 74 you can order right
as I've said and I'll keep saying Mr
Jones is that that we will make the
decision in the middle part of the 2020s
and a lot of that will depend on the the
scenarios that we see but also what
happens to the Future combat air system
so if we get the you can't land on our
cards if we get these 74 then
and the 48 we've got at the moment that
is uh enough at the moment for our
commitments to Nato our NATO air
policing
yeah that's right I mean if you if you
want a question is it is is does the UK
need more common aircraft then the
answer or combat air capability then the
answer to that is yes and that's why
um the government's in committed to the
48 and to go beyond that to the 74. but
as you said it starts not just about
numbers it's about capability so
investing in enhancements to Typhoon
further enhancements to F-35 and
ultimately I'm sure we'll come on to it
um uncrewed capabilities and this big
investment that we're making in in the
future combat assets we need to make
some are you okay because that's one
last question in terms of the mix
between the Navy and the res
um and include those is every pilot
trained to land on
two briefly the short answer is yes so
it
the carrier qualification comes around
um
periodically so some Pilots will be
doing that for the first part time some
Partners will be doing it at the same
time but every Pilot Air Force or navy
will be able to learn full train of
Pilots it shouldn't really matter
whether RAF or Royal Navy that's exactly
right both built to land on carriers
yeah that's exactly right thanks
okay you uh Robert do you have a quick
one on the Storm there's two very brief
ones just going back to Ukraine um
firstly I mean great to see the
announcement about pilot training any
sports Ukraine uh that can be given the
best
um I appreciate it for basic training
not and it's not phase two mfts can you
just reassure me that it's not gonna
have an impact on RF pilot training
we haven't quite
uh worked out yet with the ukrainians
exactly what that is going to look like
and until we understand that we can't
absolutely understand the impact it will
have on our flying training system
because clearly we'll require a capacity
um but as the secretary of state has
said on several occasions that our
priority is to support our Ukrainian
brothers and sisters and so we'll need
to make a judgment on on what impact
that might be as you know and I've no
doubt we'll come to this we have a
number of people who've already
qualified through the elementary flying
training system and been through that
process who are in our system so
certainly in the short term I don't
anticipate it having an impact but we'll
need to understand as we work out with
the ukrainians what what they need to
come back in yeah the second one quickly
uh it was impressive to see Storm Shadow
Supply to Ukraine given how long it took
to take it from tornado to Typhoon are
you able to share with us how that's
been done whether it's Airborne Circle
24 or ground-based
um well it does an operationally
sensitive question I'm afraid
right
okay we'll try and find out that another
way
um let's just a couple points before we
leave Ukraine because we're going to
move on
um firstly on the uh
a capability that's being sent there you
talk about trench warfare what we're
seeing though and then we're going to
give a poor analogy because sandwiches
have mentioned but if we go on a picnic
and Minister you bring the sandwiches
you bring the drinks you bring the
blanket and I bring the cups and so
forth if I don't turn up or one of those
doesn't determine the picnic doesn't
happen now NATO works on the assumption
that people will turn up to fight on the
day and what's happening is Ukraine is
they're going around with a begging Bowl
trying to find the necessary kit for
them to win the war in Ukraine and that
is the disjoint between our capabilities
and what we're talking about and the war
that is actually happening would you
recognize that there is that problem
that actually it's whoever the Coalition
that is willing to step forward on the
day to then provide the necessary kit
that's needed to win the battle in a
short time period I think the secretary
of state has frequently used the phrase
convening power in the sense that I mean
I think we clearly have stepped up to
the mark as a country alongside the US
bin that is absolutely understood and
within that that has convened I use that
phrase enabling other countries to come
forward
um I think there have been very positive
steps now taken from other nations I
think we can say this is now a proper
effort across our allies
um and it maximizes the total effect
going into Ukraine no it does that's
maybe the point it was for perhaps for
another day more deeper but the
capability of NATO is phenomenal that
stands alone what's been given to
Ukraine is not enough it's about to turn
into a frozen conflict and that's the
disjoint between what we have in our box
in our capability in NATO and what's
actually being given to the ukrainians
the biggest deficit they have is fast
Jets that's very very clear you wonder
why it's going to trench warfare you
said it yourself nobody's got the air
superiority and therefore that's why
it's ended up being a horrible Ground
Battle so the question is oh when are we
going to realize this and be able to put
this fire out
well I mean obviously I can only speak
for the UK government and we have just
made this very substantial uh well
announcement about a very substantial
contribution
um other than taking away from the
British constitution whatsoever this is
a collective effort and Community power
is
the points made the second point I had
is to do with the B variant because the
first time I've heard an answer to I
think it was to Kevin's question
that all 74 of the f-35s are to be the B
variant can you confirm that is the case
I can I can also confirm I've said it's
the committee before you have oh sorry I
didn't really I thought there's still a
question as to whether we're going to
use the sorry and then and we'll use go
further so 138
what would it be or you have made no
decisions on that either no decisions on
that no decisions on that I'm going 238
June no I don't think we will but I'm
not sure we'll get to 74 either but
there we go I think it should be clear
on the 74. that is funded and that is
planned and that's that's been committed
to by the government clearly you've got
to negotiate and you've got to take the
deliveries but just to reassure you that
that number of 74 was committed to five
e3s were funded as well and then that
then disappeared so it doesn't always
happen on the day does it um I want to
get to Emma Davis is a quick one too
yeah no it's a supplementary to this
point is them on the next question go
okay just very quickly uh they said it
will be far better if uh the Navy
reinstated a proper Fleet air arm and
kept all the Stovall B variants in the
RAF got future aircraft and got a
variants that's where I was suggesting
as to whether that that what that debate
whether what would the base have been
had or not what would be the problem
with that that'd be far more
straightforward yeah I've been in the uh
Fleet arm now for 38 years I've gone all
through the transition through
Harrier and the Harriet Force
we are far more effective when we can
operate the aircraft Land and Sea it
gives us actually more productivity it
gives us more flexibility so the fact
that we've got joint squadrons and we're
able to operate the aircraft from land
or sea actually the only nation in the
world that has that equal capability and
actually the intent of being able to do
it land and sea for me gives us far more
flexibility so personally is a fleet arm
officer I I support it it's the right
way to go and I've always had and always
happen Okay let's move on to the heavier
lift aircraft thanks chair and welcome
Minister just turn into Hercules so the
outgoing chief of air staff told us
there'd be a shortfall this decade with
tactical airlift and there'd be a
capability Gap when the hurt release is
retired early in favor of the Year 400
yet Minister yourself and the Secretary
of State have said that there will be no
loss of capability can you clear up for
me who's right
uh well I think actually it's not a loss
of capability it's a gain of capability
because the secretary of state is very
clearly believes this is
um a Next Generation aircraft ahead of
the Hercules now just to be clear as I
said in orals and we all recognize there
is huge affection for the Hercules it is
still doing a fantastic job
um many countries in the world will
continue to use it and clearly
um will make choices about our Hercules
which will we are planning to dispose of
but I just want to give you if you if
you like a summation of why we think
there is that credibility superiority
um in a nutshell it can carry twice as
much 50 further 25 minutes we are very
as a committee very familiar with the
stats of the two and it isn't a
competition between one or the other
it's that they complement each other
particularly something Richard Drex has
been very firm about is the niche
capabilities of the Hercules now at
least it's with single and double chalk
parachute jumps that come out of there
sorry yeah sorry I was about to come in
on that putting the affection for it to
one side this committee was also told
that some of its Niche capabilities
can't be transferred to the a400 but
that Minister's thought that that risk
was tolerable so you're saying it'll be
improved but actually what we're hearing
is that some of those Niche capabilities
will no longer be available so so what
are those capabilities we're losing I
I'm going to come to uh in a moment but
can I just
um I appreciate you know the stats there
are people around this they will know
every single stat about every single
aircraft there is
um in the world pretty much
um but
um I think there is one that is
particularly important
um and that is that on that crucial
operation in Sudan
um the maximum number of people that was
carried out by the Hercules was 143 the
maximum from the a400 was 251 and
um yes it's a yes it's just I'm going to
come to the second Point forgive me and
I know it's your first question but that
is incredibly important and we have to
ask ourselves if we were in that last
250 batch of evacuees we knew it's the
last plane out would we rather it be an
a400 when you could carry us all
Hercules would be 100 sure we thought
you respect my question is about what
Niche capability is are we losing the
ones that ministers said were tolerable
and the risk was worth taking what what
are those capabilities I picked that up
because it was my answer to the question
and the bit you missed out was I said
until 2025 yeah so there's a gap from
when the Hercules goes out of service to
when the a400m picks up all of the
transforms all of those capabilities and
the niche issues that are that where the
Gap is is around the airdrop and the
kind of things that we can drop from
from the aircraft my point laws that
ministers were fully aware of that issue
when they made the decision and nothing
has changed
to for ministers to change their mind so
that that's the Gap that we have for 18
months two years
and I just ask as well about some of the
reports this week has it been cleared
yet for the Special Forces missions such
as dropping a ball off the back of the
plane for hostage rescue missions at Sea
it was reported that this week we don't
comment on Special Forces capabilities
again sorry what about a royal Navy boat
I think that's a cheeky question I don't
think we can get an HMS type 26 in the
back of an 800m even though it is you
can certainly Okay
the reason there's two others who want
to come in this because this is a
vaccine question I hear you say you
can't comment on Special Forces
the trouble is is that you are dealing
with procurement and removing an asset
which will affect Special Forces
we know a lot of spec festivals because
we've been told so and dropping boats
out the back or throwing um Personnel
out the back through parachutes and so
forth you are losing a capability and
you say it's going to come in at 2025
the French are going through the same
rigmarole here and they're suffering
they're meeting the same challenges that
you're going to bump into yourselves
so it is important that we understand I
you can't hide behind this shroud of
secrecy of what the SF you know do we
know exactly what they do that's
actually very very
clear what we also realize is what they
won't be able to do if the Hercules is
dropped
I think if I may come in on that so I
spoke to director Special Forces uh last
week specifically about his views on
a400m and he was really clear to me
that following some training that
they've done earlier this year and the
the polar bear the operation in Sudan
just how impressed he had been with
a400m it could achieve all of the
potential courses of action we know it's
a bigger aircraft it's going to take
more people if you take that instead of
the Hercules we're not saying one or the
other we're saying they both complement
each other Richard do you want to come
in here or can I can I just can I just
finish off that that final point though
because it's dark you're supposed to
keep repeating it
shake us off where we're trying to go we
know it's a big aircraft it takes more
people that we accept that
that's not what I've just said uh chair
what I'm getting at is that director
Special Forces said that 800m could do
all of the potential courses of action
that they examined when they went into
Sudan
so the point is that it can do okay the
majority of the tasks not sure all the
SF capabilities were tested in Sudan but
let's let's explore that that is true
Robert
okay I'm going to defer to uh Mr traxy
wants to pick up on Special Forces thing
and then often
um yeah sorry it just sit down
I I think I think the chairman said it's
the complementary role that they play
now there's a gap as you've said to 20
2025 and actually the Hercules was due
was going to have another seven years as
I understand it until like 2030. so that
Gap has been forced upon you I'm
assuming my money
um we have spoken to the special forces
and obviously I've got contacts still
being an ex-serviceman in them they are
concerned of the loss of this aircraft
and from what I hear about the a400 it's
still got problems
it's still got issues coming so we hear
from the Airbus report that we were told
yesterday there are more issues to come
in Sudan I believe we heard a question
in the house that two of the aircraft
have problems if I remember no okay well
that's obviously misinformation
so and the aircraft is still not 100
reliable whereas the Hercules is a true
tested
friend not least the special forces in
the parachute regiment
it's smaller and I don't think big is
necessary beautiful I think this is a
misconception it really isn't but you've
got such a good proven aircraft which
we're now sadly getting rid of
presumably because of money
well I I mean if I just on on the money
on the money as it were
um it is a fact that when you are
looking at
what platforms you're going to have and
all these big considerations money is a
factor there is no getting away from
that what I would say if you like to
turn it round is
at this moment in time were we to
suddenly you turn having had a very
managed
transition tapered transition to the
position at the end of June where the
Hercules is withdrawn were we to reverse
that it's not well the amount of Thrones
it's not worth marriage because you
yourself have said there's going to be a
gap in capability that's not well
managed
I simply said a managed transition
um whereby it is gradually withdrawn and
the a400 takes up the task lines Etc but
the point I I was going to say is were
we to change that
um there would then be a cost that we
hadn't budgeted for that is absolutely
correct there will be the cost of
maintain of having to maintain the
Hercules alongside the a400 they would
be the foregone Revenue stream from
potential disposal sales
um so you know it is it is never a
straightforward question but you're
absolutely right there would be costs
that we have not budgeted for and that
therefore would mean we would have to
look at other items in the a budget
potentially that they would have to to
come out of the plan I I fear there's a
sense of deja vu to this this
conversation and understand where we are
Robert do you want to move on to nice
focusing on some aspects of this firstly
can I just put to one side yes it's a
legendary aircraft yes we're sorry to
see it go but we're not we don't have
sentimental concerns here it's
capability concerns or capacity concerns
that we have there are three concerns
over this transition the first of them
is the special forces capability now
you've addressed that
um essentially that is that'll be
transitioned by 2025 I think it's your
answer and obviously we'll have to keep
an eye on that but I understand that
point I'm going to put that to one side
because everyone else has dealt with
that the other two concerns are the ones
that I want to drift to to address which
are in any event linked which are its
availability and the overall Fleet size
I'm just going to look at those in
particular because it's that that I'm
concerned about now when secretary of
state says in the chamber no overall
loss in capable
his words obviously he's right it's a
bigger aircraft it can carry more it can
carry faster but no matter how good it
is it can't be in two places at once and
it's that and the availability of task
lines is what I'm concerned by so now
the when you were last in front of me uh
with Kaz um G Marshall the figures that
I put on task lines came from November
2022 which was a written question and it
said at the time that c130j had 1 800
available task lines and a400 had 1 500.
what's the position now
so um I think the first thing to say
um is I want to bring in uh DGA on
availability because obviously this is
about the supply chain and there have
been some change come to forgive me I
want to ask about that but I want to do
that in a second I've got a specific
point in my mind that I want to do well
now I'll give you the chance to answer
yeah but I just want to deal with the
task line availability at the moment
what I want to understand is how many
task lines c130j has been offering to
defense over the course of the last year
or at least since November 2022 and how
many task lines a400 has been offering
to defense because if you're expecting
the latter to take over the former I'd
expect to see a one for one replacement
I'll give you the these numbers in per
day rather than the overall number and I
don't know what period that was over so
forgive me but it gives you a sense of
it
so
um as of uh today a uh C-130 is
delivering four task lines
and by and 800m is delivering around
nine and will be 10 by by the summer in
800m was delivering only four task lines
and C130 was delivering around six so
there's a total of ten so that situation
has improved your point about the fact
if you retire C130 you you lose capacity
in terms of number of points of presence
number of aircraft in the air of course
that's right of course that's right and
that will that will force us to make
decisions around priorities and to move
lower priority Freights lower priority
tasks to in other ways right okay can
you write to us and give us some updated
figures on those because you were very
clear in answers back in November as to
the amount of task lines that were
available
um written questions 8th and 17th of
November can you get those updated in
terms of the task lines available and
secondly how many of each aircraft was
serviceable uh throughout those months
can you update that will help us
understand and put Flesh on the bones of
the point you've made and I think to be
fair to you both you and Kaz last time
were were up front and accepting that
there is a shortfall there what I'm
trying to do is to quantify exactly what
that is and what it is that we're losing
yeah all right
um thanks for that
um so let's now turn um to oh sorry
before I do the other point uh was uh
that was mentioned last time is about
the the further six by the end of the
decade
um are you able to give us any update on
that because that would assuage some of
the concerns that we have
there's no there's no definitive update
at the moment on there
all right uh keep uh pushing on that
that would deal with your U-turn Point
Minister which I accept if you were to
turn your
change your mind but further airframe
capacity is is what we need to be
looking for if I just make one point if
I may
um you know in preparing for this um
obviously because I came to your
consistency uh Mr courts to visit Bryce
Norton and meet the crews
um and I I asked
um air Commodore John Lyle who is the uh
commander of Mobility I said to him in
July could you do Sudan and he said
absolutely and so for me what is
absolutely crucial aside from the other
points is that we would still be able to
perform our critical commitments so I
accept that and you can do Sue down but
that's one operation in isolation what
I'm concerned about is the air Mobility
force is being asked to do more and more
as one of the most heavily tasked bits
of Defense anyway and if it can do Sudan
fine but it may not be able to do
something else at the same time I will
write to you again with the follow-up to
my last written answer
right and now now turn into availability
on which thank you'd be great for your
assistance on this so we had some
written evidence from you on so inquiry
which said that a400 haven't yet reached
the expectations that you would have and
the demand is going to be made before
Hercules retires now that point is hard
Upon Us it'll be with us anytime now
have those demands been met
so um The Challenge we were given was to
get ourselves up to nine task lines as
an average by uh April this year with
the aim of uh as the chief said is
moving towards 10 and then 11 and
onwards as we mature the aircraft so
where we got today is we are sat between
eight and nine now the reason behind
that is principally at the beginning
it's come up by about 25 over the last
18 months yeah one further point when a
task line is declared operational and
available for defense that's at the
beginning of the day do you update it if
it goes on serviceable during the course
of the day yeah so we're taking that we
try and take an average from the
beginning of the day to the end of the
day so it might not be the same aircraft
that comes up so over the last two or
three days we've had nine and ten at 6
30 in the morning and that subsequently
can change during the day but
fundamentally it means that other
aircraft could be coming online when
other aircraft come back unserviceable
so it's not necessarily same aircraft
that fundamentally that's that's how we
take an average we also take an average
over a month and we also take an average
every quarter because not just on this
platform but any platform you can
appreciate it goes up and down it's not
just this platform it's any platform
okay and eight to nine task lives of
course is the same thing you've just
given me there I mean that is out of a
total of we've got 21 airframes at the
moment the last is due to come literally
this month is coming in this literally a
few in a few days I mean it's literally
being prepped as we speak that's
where does that's your aim but it's not
going to be your end you're going to
want about 15. this is our this is our
current one so so where we sit at the
moment out of a fleet of 21 we've got a
retrofit program which was a choice
because we decided to take the aircraft
early to mature it and that retrofit
program will be between three and four
aircraft going in and out all the way
out to 20 25 26 because that was that's
about getting each time you'll want to
Yeah
by that stage we will be at 22. we will
be at 22 aircraft from now aircraft but
how many task Line's average uh we
haven't got an average of task lights
out to that stage but I mean we will we
will sit at um about 15 16 wouldn't you
we will not deliver that by 2025 because
the retrofit program will continue in
Beyond 2025.
so 10 by the summer and we I would hope
that we would see that increase as
availability improves the big thing that
um economodo Anthony and I will talk
about was this this issue around
predictability and that's the work that
we're pressing DNS and Airbus to do to
improve that predictability and it is
about that so where we where we've got
to at the moment and there are three
aircraft that are in depth at any one
time because they have to be repaired so
out of the remainder we're looking to to
to generate about 75 availability that's
what we're after okay as in the short
term and that's what we're getting after
so
um it is about predictability if you
look at where we were over the last 18
months where we've come up about 25
percent
we had to resolve issues over a gearbox
modification that's now almost behind us
we've literally come up with the last
gearbox changes this month
has that resolved it has that gearbox so
we've done that so we've done so we've
done the modifications that we're
planning to do yeah absolutely those
modifications
so those yeah absolutely so those
originally the original gearbox issue
it's got all of the modifications have
been done and we've gone through the
spares to to make sure we're we're done
if you then
um look at the propellers we had we
ended up with a series of seven year
inspections that have been the majority
last year and will become this year as
well that is now largely behind us
um and uh we had issues over engine
testing and availability so we've
increased the test capacity of the
engine and some of the longer term
issues that we have with the engine
itself in terms of balancing it after
maintenance has been now been resolved
so those things are largely behind us we
are still maturing the aircraft in terms
of maintenance
because we took the aircraft first and
we are Fleet leaders invariably we hit
maintenance activity first
all of that stuff is is is gradually
maturing I go back to to uh to kazi's
point it's about the predictability but
we are up at over eight and we are
driving in the right direction
so from my perspective having taken that
early decision to mature the aircraft
and to and to and to get on top of the
productivity that will pay dividends as
we're moving forward
thanks uh final question on this and
I'll come back chair which is just the
bus sorry back on to see on Thursday and
Minister your point uh around if you
were to change your mind an alternative
which occurs is that instead of to keep
the capability rather than lose it all
together it could be gifted or
transferred or sold in some way to
NATO's strategic LF capability is that
an option that's being seriously
considered
our preferences for sort of straight
government to government sale
um and that that could obviously could
include NATO Parts obviously yeah but
specifically not to a NATO partner but
to the sac capability well but and but
just you said on gifting sorry I think
gifting or sale well I mean keeping it
within Nate I think as long as the
priority and it goes back to the point
to Mr Drax is trying to
um have as little follow-on
responsibility if you like once the
planes are disposed of because of the
impact on cost here and the impact on
the a400 and the resources needed for
that I think that's that's really why we
have that strategy that's the key
consideration when I last checked this
which was
um a couple of months ago there were 15
Nations who were shown some interest of
which
um 11 of them were NATO Nations
popular aircraft
that's a and that's it's a very fair
point I actually said in my answer I
didn't I when I said the affection just
to be clear I didn't mean that was your
reasoning I was just recognizing that
point because I see that from the
correspondence that I I get
um but you know we've made a decision in
terms of what we think is the right
capability as you've seen from orals and
Secretary of State passionately believes
this is the best thing for the Air Force
and I have to say go into your
constituency and meeting the crews they
feel very strongly the same and and
that's talking about you know I think
Squadron leaders who who were flying the
Hercules for many years but we're
drifting back together it's disputing
with you that the a400m when fully
matured when serviceable is a great
aircraft there's no difference between
us there at all it's the overall uh
availability of lift capacity to the Air
Force is what I'm concerned about
okay when we Stack Up
um tactical heavy lift capacity which is
the bigger question not whether a400 or
C-130 is it a freedom information
request was was put in we've got eight
c-130s please tell me if these figures
are wrong uh we've got 21 a400s but
eight are under what's called
sustainment which I think means
long-term repair so only 14 are then
available for your task lines and on the
c17 8 are you got eight but two are
under sustainment so when you add all
that together
um if tenor under sustainment uh eight
is soon to be scrapped that leaves 20
tactical heavy lift aircraft for the RAF
and I think the question that the
committee would be concerned about is
that is enough is that enough for our
long-term needs given the ever
increasing pressure that we're placing
um and Sudan is just one great example
or something that can pop up over the
horizon there's a longer term and it's a
very good question I agree we want to be
sure we have the capability absolutely
and the capacity they are two parts the
same thing um look I um there is a
simple Point as well which is it will be
22 very soon we understand taking
delivery of the 22nd a400 later this
month
um I just so I mentioned Sudan and the
performance and and as you can
appreciate from what really matters is
that it can deliver those critical
um uh duties if you take Ukraine
um and I think I had a written question
for Mr courts and I I wanted to furnish
a little more information which which I
you know sorry that I didn't do that
originally but I've I have looked into
it a bit more so on
um taking uh the huge amount of Kit we
have out to Ukraine actually it's been
this it's been almost entirely the C-17
in the last six months with the a400
helping as I'm said actually at weekends
um so the Hercules hasn't been required
for that as I said I've been assured we
could have done Sudan now you're but
you're right mathematically it's a very
basic Point there's clearly a limit and
that would be the case whatever the
number are I think the word productivity
has been used it is a more productive
things you can do more with each one but
that's it but that is an important Point
let's move on to another aircraft where
I'm afraid the numbers question then
comes up Mark thank you very much
um active Marshall
congratulations they they made the right
choice good luck in your new post
with regard to E7 and wedge time
one of the things from the Ukraine is
that the Russians are not slow to Chuck
around cruise missiles I think no one
would argue about that
so we have a number of fixed air defense
radar sites along the east coast so if
we were to become involved in a shooting
war with Russia it's a reasonable
planning assumption that most of those
big fix sites would fall victim to
cruise missile strikes very quickly
possibly in a matter of days maybe even
in a matter of hours
so we'd lose out it we'd lose our radar
chain we have a very limited number of
mobile Radars as you know the number is
classified but it's not a big number
we don't have any Airborne early warning
aircraft left in service we used to have
seven centuries
and we withdrew them in 2021
so we'd be blinded
in a shooting war with Russia
does that not worry you as the future
head of the royal Air Force
in the simple answer is that our ability
to see and understand what is happening
in the air domain is fundamental to our
ability to direct our forces and our
assets
and protect our country
um
you and I have had this conversation
before when you were the minister and I
think I was the assistant chief of air
staff at the time about the fact that if
nothing else we're trying to consistency
I've said this before Mr Francois you're
very consistent on this point and it's a
it's a very good point but but my uh but
my answer Remains the Same which is of
course that we
we are part of a wider NATO air defense
system
but your question about E7 and the fact
that we don't have an Airborne early
warning capability at the moment that is
that is important to us to the country
to the Air Force and to me which is why
I I give advice Admiral Thompson a hard
time and he gives Boeing a hard time to
bring in the E7 as quickly as as we can
I think you know that the E7 when it
comes into service they will be a step
change in capability and NATO will be
enormously brought in but there are just
aren't enough of them
temporarily we rely on NATO failure
cover
but in a shooting war in a large scale
shooting war with Russia it's possible
that those aircraft will be tasked
elsewhere we cannot guarantee that we
would have access to them it all depends
on the operational situation we don't
control them whereas we do control our
own or did when we had them
we're only going to have three we were
originally as the chairman has already
intimated going to have five
it's an Open Secret the RAF deeply
resisted the decision to cut from five
to three that was a ministerial decision
not a royal Air Force decision
because of regular maintenance on any
given day we're only likely to have two
that can fly and on a bad day we'll have
one one aircraft
to provide radar coverage for the whole
of the defense of the United Kingdom
that's simply not enough is it
clearly if you have more aircraft you
can deliver more capability but you'll
know
um as a former Minister that ministers
have to take difficult decisions around
relative priorities and the savings
associated with reducing from five to
three provided 700 plus million pounds
for that could be spent elsewhere in
defense and that was the decision that
ministers took well I think we'll
contest that figure Mr Jones is going to
come on to that in a minute
but but but it simply is not enough next
point they will be absolute prime
targets for our elements
the Chinese have a missile the pl-15
stroke 17 which can reach nearly 200
kilometers the Russians have something
not quite as good but similar they call
it I don't know what they call it in
Russian but it's the a-wax Killer
so we've got very few of these aircraft
and our enemies will absolutely do
everything they can to knock them out of
the sky all the more reason for having a
few more aircraft than we've currently
got
surely as we've paid for five of The
Radars Mr Jones will explore that in
more detail but we're only going to have
three aircraft it must make sense surely
to go for five wasn't it
right I'm going to preempt your question
now Mr James puts
um the how much is eating yeah
eat your fruits and your yogurt as well
um the uh and I saw the the article over
the weekend in the telegraph the number
that was referring to is the procurement
cost specifically around the aircraft
quite chunk of the savings are
associated with the infrastructure and
also the support costs associated with
it so if we wanted to bring more
aircraft into service
we would have to find at least 700 and
something million pounds over the next
seven eight years something like that in
order to be able to do that now it may
be that as we go through our further
planning process and the fact that the
Americans have committed to buying E7 28
I think that that they they've
identified that may open up
opportunities but that would have to be
a balance of investment judgment that
ministers would want to take across the
fence what the Air Force doesn't have is
is spare cash to be able to go and let
Mr Jones run that one to ground
we can't use the Crow's Nest aew
helicopter the conversion of the Merlin
for the Navy that's an aw system but
after seven years it still doesn't work
properly
now
to May 2023 we've spent 414 414 million
on that helicopter
out of a projected whole life cost of
459 million
how many are we actually going to have
because there's some confusion about
whether every one of our 30 or so
Merlins will be converted for Crow's
Nest or whether there's just going to be
a small number so vice admiral what
actually is the answer on that how many
Crow's nests are we going to have I I
don't know the answer that I can come
back to you but I don't know the answer
with respect to your DGL this is
absolutely in your lane this fortunately
sounds like an excuse and please don't
take it as much I don't do helicopters I
know that sounds bizarre but so I can't
give you that specific answer I
apologize but I I don't have it just
sorry just quickly who's responsible for
the procurement of crow which bit of DNS
is responsible so it sits under digiland
my colleague so because Airborne early
warning helicopter sits under DG land
and that's just consequence of how the
funding flows all right just quickly I
apologize and then we'll go to Kevin
so far it's taken over seven years
doesn't work properly we still haven't
got ioc on the carrier 21 deployment it
performed very poorly how Pony is
classified but it was not a stunning
success okay just hang on after seven
years we still haven't integrated the
radar onto the helicopter in the
Falklands War we integrated a radar onto
a helicopter in three months
why 40 years ago were able to do in
three months what 40 years on we can't
do in seven years
so the conversation I had with my
colleague yesterday
um is that from a design perspective
those Kors that were set out for the uh
the aircraft the kuos key user
requirements I know as the the
operational specification it's
um simplistically will be met and the
rectification of the the current
shortfalls will be uh will be dealt with
by industry at their cost
well okay just quickly in Latin I
understand the Latin term word is basket
case
we just try this is why this committee
gets so fed up let's get this woman
cock-ups like Miss pill anyway over to
you
thanks Jim before we get into this
question can I just ask something uh
Chief Marshall about the tasking of E7
what will its tasking be is it part of a
net more of a broader NATO tasking of
what will actually be when it it uh we
offer a certain number of missions into
NATO
and unlike other nations we retain
command and control of the assets and
then we choose to through negotiation to
hand it into NATO if there are specific
missions that NATO wanted to undertake
and that's an agreement that we make
with the NATO Airborne early warning and
control
um commanders that's that's part of a
bigger NATO commitment in terms of
correct so NATO has its own Airborne
early warning capability the UK
contributes to that but retains its own
assets we didn't put the assets into the
NATO pool
can I ask then in terms of the reduction
from five to three uh why is it taking
so long to submit the business case for
E3
yeah sure so so the business case at the
moment or the final business case
because we had a acquisition business
case to start
um is is currently being generated it's
due to go through approval
um between Summer and the end of this
year what's taking us the time is we
have not yet completed the negotiations
on the support solution so once that is
finished then we'll be in a position to
finalize the full business case because
embedded within the full business case
is the whole life cost of the aircraft
and where we stand at the moment is
we've done the acquisition piece because
we wanted to get going with the
acquisition and we're now finalizing the
support cost
now within those support costs going
back to the point we made earlier about
the 7 7 15 720 million in terms of
savings what you've seen so far is the
acquisition element of that you've got
the support element of that to come
which is another 300. so that's
effectively what the business case is
currently looking at
full business case we basically bought a
car without actually any service plan
for its future
so so we remember that we bought this
aircraft off the shelf so from a
perspective of how we finalize the
support solution that work is ongoing
but we are in a position to be able to
know how to support the aircraft it's
about finalizing the negotiation if I
want to put up a new car and uh I bought
it without any
let's say I was going to keep it for 20
years and I wanted to know what it was
going to cost every year for the next 20
years to keep it on the road or keep it
up to date
are you saying that you actually don't
know what it's going to cost to uh
a week so we could so we can do
comparative costs with what it costs
Australia to operate the aircraft for
example we've been operating aircraft
for a while but in terms of finalizing
negotiations with industry we are still
doing that as we speak can I just if I
add a little bit of color so it would be
like saying do you know you buy yourself
a new card you know in five years time
how much the garage is going to charge
you for that servicing the point is that
you negotiate the precise costs
associated with the support solution
as you get a better understanding of it
but you do know which franchise you're
going to
that you've had years to work this out
you've had years
why don't you work this out before you
withdrew the E3 a wax
you've had years
okay this is coming to you uh well
in terms of their overall program we
don't know what it's going to cost so
you've said it's by cutting the two
aircraft out you're going to save 700
million we actually don't know do we
because we haven't actually finalized it
and what are the cost inflation in terms
of the program
so in from a acquisition perspective
it's a it's a firm price so we the
acquisition is is is fixed in terms of
its price
yeah but then we've obviously got to put
into uh that the cost of the dollar
exchange rate because supporting dollars
isn't it yeah so in terms of our whole
life costing and planning that that is
something that we do routinely in terms
of estimating in terms of when we
predict how much we need in the budget
that is done using standard indices
defense economic Industries well it is
but it's it's going to mean that we've
got it's another asset it's another
another program which we've bought which
means that uh we're at the mercy of the
currency markets aren't we to be
um honest that's the case with
it would be but if you actually look at
the increase in the last few years a
number of uh
off-the-shelf Solutions of the United
States it's actually given a huge
exposure to the defense budget in terms
of the effect of currency exchange isn't
it yes the currency exchange as the
pound is weakened against the dollar
from I don't know 142 as it was a few
years ago down to 120. but somebody says
there's a 15 increase in but it's
something like 30 procurement budget now
is actually in dollars isn't it
um I haven't seen the report from last
year but I don't think it's that high
now it was higher a couple of years ago
when we had a heart when we had a higher
number of so Apache and p8 and
um F-35 which were nominated in in
dollars Richard sorry because I serve on
the PAC I know but about this so we we
have an up an upper and lower band
across the 10 years of the equipment
plan the lowest dollar exchange rate we
had in the Assumption I think from
memory was 127. that was right at the
bottom and at the I think today the
Dollar's around 125. so
already we're out and if you if you
magnify that over the 10 years of the
equipment plan you're talking a very
large amount of money now the 720
million just quickly
we're paying we were going to pay 1.9
billion approximately for for
um
no it was near or two point yeah well
the the total cost now is 2.155 billion
for free aircraft whereas we were going
to pay 1.9 billion for five so it's not
just the other way around right okay
well in which case how is the taxpayer
still got value for money then okay if
we were going to pay all right 2.155
billion for five and we're now going to
pay 1.9 billion for three how is that
good value for money
I think isn't The crucial point on the
and forgive me but on the 700 and I
think it's probably 720 million saving
is that a lot of that comes from the uh
moving it to lossy mouth the sharing of
the workforce you would have done that
Minister whether it was five or three no
they were going to go to lost it so what
is that 720 million pound quote saving
based on how do you calculate that may I
put that in so
um when it was five aircraft this
decision was for it to get an RAF
wardington it's a part of moving it to
lossy mouth meant that the
infrastructure built which was getting
up towards 200 million pounds of savings
associated with infrastructure that you
didn't then need at Waddington there
were savings associated with the
procurement which is the numbers that
you've given and also Savings of over
300 million pounds associated with
supporting only three aircraft rather
than the five over the ten and when you
take that together that's where the 700
million comes from now I was involved in
the
um I'm good at maths Mr Francois we can
work through that I know Richard but if
I could just go just finish off the
point about value for money
the um I was involved in that in my
previous role and you as you would
imagine you would expect the treasury to
want to examine the value for money of
the program when you reduce from five to
three with a saving that you've
described and I can just the the
treasury agreed that that remained value
for money and when you compared it to
the costs of other nations we were
getting a really good deal okay I want
to we need to move forward Kevin can you
complete radar morning
but it's not been approved by the
treasure yet does it yeah it was the
acquisition acquisition but the second
part of it the second part which is the
long terms that we include the long-term
support and some of the final elements
that that's the bit that will be
included in the full business case
that's not being approved yet that's not
been through uh it's not been approved
through treasury yet as I understand it
what happens if the treasure come back
and say well we don't approve this it
would be very that would be very that
would be very difficult Mr James former
yeah correct I just asked the last thing
then about the radio is it true then
that we bought we bought five and we're
only going to use three
that is correct
um but the additional two we've decided
to keep because it allowed us to reduce
the spares purchased by about a hundred
million pounds so that was part of the
savings associated with with it we so we
didn't we would normally if we'd had
five we would have had to buy all five
and buy some spares to sustain it
because we only got three aircraft we
can use those two Radars breaking spares
as well just to keep it in case you need
those well there are seven three seven
so it's rather easier to get spares for
them
all right gosh in terms of the the two
you've so what's the cost of each radar
though I mean that is a sensitive figure
but it is ready but in terms of UPC but
the return was
um was a good return proportionally a
good return Have you bought have you
bought them as made up Radars or in bits
um
yeah they come as a complete package but
fundamentally you can break them down
into spares
say mister I when I saw this I said can
I just be clear is this some sort of you
know we'd signed the contract for five
and then we made Radars and we then made
it on the planes it was you know was it
language but you know was it a mistake
as it were and to be clear absolutely
assured this was a conscious decision
because of the saving involved and what
it would mean in terms of the spare
parts Etc they will go in the inventory
for the spare parts over the next few
seconds that is exactly yeah and we it's
concluded we got better value for doing
it that way rather than trying to sell
The Radars back to Boeing actually at
the time we didn't have the US hadn't
committed that's one last question about
workshare I mean obviously have now I
mean
Boeing are doing very well out to the UK
defense industry they put very little
back in in terms of uh
investment in jobs in the UK are we
actually going to have any of this
maintenance of work in terms of all
access for industry to actually take
part in any of the through life support
for this at one time this is about 700
jobs involved so the maintenance say the
work up in lossy mouth in terms of the
long-term maintenance of the aircraft
will be done through through UK jobs
you're aware I mean you've been to SDS
and you've seen there are about 90 jobs
up there in terms of skilled Workforce
so those are are planned jobs
jobs whoever got the contract will have
had to provide the maintenance debtline
it's not it's not going on giving
anything out of that that's just a
maintenance function they don't put any
production into this country or very
little it's all do they
not for this specific area no no at all
well for all the work that Boeing have
had out of the RAF what have they put
but I can go and see a big GE plant at
Cheltenham what have Boeing put back
into this country
so there are a number of jobs within the
supply chain so there are Engineers
doing work for example in places such as
Leonardo with the defensive Aid Suites
so there are there are other jobs
across the supply chain
look no but okay we do need a couple of
people want to come in here Kevin if you
want to conclude say that even at this
late stage
you might want to keep pressurizing
Boeing I accept some of this is
government government contract therefore
it can't be you know but I do think
Minister you need to be screwing Boeing
down to the floor and saying if we are
it's procure in these things we do
actually want to see investment
not just in terms of jobs but actually
technology and development in this
country because
you know they've done very well and put
very little back into this country in
terms of technology for what they've had
in a portion of uh contracts without
okay
um Dave did you want to go very quickly
yes um air Vice Marshall the previous
Min DP immediate previous one and issued
on the record figures for five-year
credit which I think you'll recognize
five aircraft 2.16 billion three
aircraft 1.89 billion that's it so that
gives you a unit cost for each aircraft
if we bought five or 432 million we only
want three so that's a unit price of 630
million that's an inflation of 200
million per aircraft is my maths correct
um your arithmetic is correct but your
assumptions are incorrect because not
all of the costs associated with the
contract are specifically for the
airframes well no indeed because
there'll be things like training
infrastructure there'll be simulators
there'll be some elements of them
infrastructure in there but you're right
the per unit cost associated with E7
when we bought three rod and five went
up that was what was assessed by the
treasury is still representing value for
money right interesting and finally uh
also on the record from the immediate
previously mndp is that in terms of
addressing the capability Gap it was
cited that Crow's Nest is available
is Crow's Nest available FOC entirely
available functioning properly as
anticipated not even ioc
no and it's meant to FOC was meant to be
achieved in May 23 can we hear from
anybody if it has reached if we see in
May 23.
so it's an it's a Navy program delivered
by uh DG DG land
um and it's been a little while since we
did agree on that one I'm afraid I said
everything yet on Crow's Nest no I
haven't can I suggest you get one and
could you update the committee on what
they tell you thank you I think we did
agree when that we would the Chairman's
Keen to move on that's 720 million is a
smoke and mirrors number
number
the subconscious no longer has that
money to spend subcommittee will look at
this in great detail okay all right but
just quickly if you've already spent the
money on the maintenance facilities
that's cool you're gonna whether it's
five or three you've already bought five
Radars you're running a massive
operational risk surely the sensible
thing to do is to buy two more 737s and
go up to five isn't it is it that would
still they wouldn't be free
um so say that now I know you know that
but that's that is the point we would
still have to make that financial
decision now you it may be that the
committee wants to make a conclusion and
a recommendation that is the case uh to
us and we will obviously have to respond
to that but you know we are in the
middle of the Defense command paper
we're looking at all the bounce
investment decisions and
um in doing that if we spend something
on one thing that's something we can't
spend elsewhere we cannot Escape that
basic logic okay a final point of this I
mean because we wouldn't move on to some
other things but um uh air Chief
Marshall can you give me scenarios where
the E7 would be has been deployed or
could be deployed would you agree the
high north for example would you agree
over at UK airspace East flank of NATO
maybe over Sudan uh the gulf are these
typical locations where they could be
deployed yeah and if you look at the
final year of operation of the E3 it
operated for example in outer Cyprus to
cover both the eastern flank of NATO or
could move and cover up their operations
okay so it's a it's a useful asset to
have I think the message hugely
important I hope you're receiving from
this committee is that three is simply
enough not enough because one could be
used for training one could actually be
broken or need basic repair leaving you
one only and you just gave a whole list
of scenarios whereby the E7 could be
deployed when this cut was made from
five to three the American Embassy
called me and said this is mad what are
you doing operationally this is
dangerous because you're not going to be
able to provide the necessary i-star
assets that are f-35s particularly need
um for for modern day air combat and
that's the piece that I think is
misunderstood we can go through all
these numbers this was a a fund cutting
exercise that's what this was about and
we've lost operational capability and I
hope that's the message that the come
and you procurements will take away to
say if there's any way that we can
advance and return back to five it would
then make sense we appreciative of our
visit to Birmingham amazing bit of Kit
what they're doing there indeed they
have capacity to build more and I hope
that's something also he'll consider
NATO are thinking of purchasing this
themselves to have E7 for them it would
be good to see those that them being
built in Birmingham itself if there's I
think we've I get your message we've
made it very very clear can we move over
to
um uh to Flying training if we make now
we had a very interesting briefing from
Ascent flying training limited who do
much of the uh the training for the RAF
and in very simple language there are as
you know three phases to the training
phase one lasts 12 months
phase two last two and a half years
and then phase three lasts another year
that suggests that in about what four
and a half years you can have a fast jet
pilot you can have an a400 pilot or you
could actually have an Apache pilot as
well
we went to Myron and we met one pilot it
had taken him 10 years to go from flash
to bang so there's something
fundamentally wrong with our training
program
before we go into the detail
sir can you elaborate on on what's
happened and what and how you're going
to fix it and we've talked to the
committee before about it and there are
some examples like the one you cite
where it is completely unacceptably too
long for people to go through the flying
training system the the history of this
goes back uh to the Nao report back in
the early 2000s where it recommended
that the changes to the way in which
flying training was delivered and the
the solution was the military flying
training system that you're you're aware
of in 2015 so that was sized in 2012
around expectations of what the size of
the front line was going to be in 2015
there's a decisions to grow the size of
the front front line
um partly because the increasing number
of typhoon squadrons but also decision
to run on Hercules Etc and so the size
of the the throughput had to be
increased and at the same time we went
through a period from 2016 15 16 onwards
where every asset apart from every
aircraft apart from Hawk was was
replaced so by the time we got to 2019
when all those new aircraft were coming
into service we had a big backlog of
Pilots waiting to go through Elementary
flying training over the period since
2019 to today that situation has
improved significantly but that bulge
has moved through the through the system
and as the chief talked about when we
saw you on the first of February
the impact of covid and the fact that
many more people stayed in the service
at that time than was originally
expected that the front line was full so
there weren't gaps there for new pilots
to go into and then the second thing is
that decisions taken in 2020 removed
cockpits for people to go to that
they've been recruited for several years
ago and so that's contributed to the to
add to that you've now got for example
cutting the Hercules you've got exactly
these Pilots that now need to be
retrained in some form if they give us
or wherever but as the chief laid out
when we came to see you a couple of
months ago I'm pleased to say that we're
seeing improvements in the time it's
taking people to move through the system
number of Pilots Holding is is reducing
as well and about and by the time we get
into the kind of middle of next year
quite a lot of those pipelines will be
at that optimized level and I was at RF
Cromwell last week I was chatting to
some of the pilots uh who had graduated
a little while ago chatted to a young
woman who had completed an emergency
flying training was about it was next
year would start Texan which is the next
phase of the fast jet training and she
was expecting to be at the front line
through the ocu in 2026 and so that's
the so that's the kind of speed of
improvement but you're absolutely right
where it was was not acceptable due to
after Factor Texan because phase two is
where you then decide or move into your
either your heavy lift your multi-engine
your fast jet or you're going to Rotary
now the example you gave for going from
the Texan The Next Step will be the hawk
and it's the availability of of the hawk
that has been fundamental that's what
we've discovered as one of the crucial
bottlenecks in getting people through
the system because at one point you're
down to six available
um Hawks for the program when you're
actually looking on a good day I think
between 15 and 18. so can you tell the
committee how that's improved what are
we doing and also about the contract too
of providing Hawks because there is a
question all this other aircraft that
you've in Texan and so forth all these
other ones that were talking about
Phantom the prefect the Juno and so
forth they're all provided by through
the contract that is given to ascent
why did the Moto choose to keep the
contract of availability of the hawk and
not include that in the ascent contract
too
um I well I'm going to turn to uh
Thompson to talk about the contract and
the like but
um you'd have to go back I think it was
to Jeff Hoon was the Secretary of State
when the decision
uh and
um that decision was taken to to buy
Hawk T2 at that stage knowing that there
was a requirement to upgrade other
aspects of it I I was I just put a
junior officer at that time so I'm
afraid I'm not privy to what those
decisions were but in terms of where we
are today with Hawk Rick is in a very
good place too
um so in terms of the work that we did
um about two two years ago two and a
half years ago to bring together what
was about five or six contracts under
one to improve the availability of Hawk
pending the engine that work was done
um because it was demonstrated it was
the most cost effective way I cannot
answer your question about why we
decided to keep leave Hawk as GFE gfx
but fundamentally the decision to to to
to negotiate it's not been impressive in
a second month it's not been impressive
and there is a big question whether the
med does this stuff well uh whether you
slide it across the table to a company
that's actually got a better track
record of doing it and is actually from
what we've understood would be Keen to
take on that role so maybe minister is
something you could take away and say
why don't we Slide the the hawk
responsibility over to
um over to the uh the ascent light yes
what is the what are the underlying
there may be several underlying reasons
for the unavailability of all I
understand that they had a problem with
the engine and it was module one and
then module yeah so the case so our
current problem with the is purely down
to the engine I mean the aircraft itself
uh the support solution the the depth
maintenance at Valley uh is performing
well
is purely the engine that is currently
driving down our availability what are
the problems of the engine how long
they've been going on and what's the
recovery path so our uh there are two
separate issues with the engine the
first one is an issue with the life of
the compressor and the second one is uh
within the life of the the turbine those
are two components which we've had to
reduce the life on because of a um of
design and Manufacturing issues so those
have been around now for about uh a year
when we first had the problem with the
with the compressor and about uh six
seven months ago we ended up with a
problem with the turbine both of those
now are yeah
both of those sorry is this bachelor the
problem with fan blades again yes which
is the same on the civilian side that's
been a problem with uh with some of the
civilian uh engines as well
which there is not an equivalent of this
engine oh but fan blade problems have
been part of the part of the issue on
the Civil side as well
so what are you doing with Rolls-Royce
to say is it Rolls-Royce engine no so
it's a Rolls-Royce contract but it is a
combination of Rolls-Royce and saffron
in terms of fan blades so the front of
the aircraft is made by saffron and the
rear is made by Rolls-Royce but it is a
partnership who produces the fan blades
front is manufactured by saffron and the
and the rear is manufactured by
Rolls-Royce
right so just my forecast just to the
other one that came up was just to do
with the the feed-in systems of the Army
Navy versus the RF when it comes to
Rotary as well I understand that when
they begin phase two
they both come from very different
training mechanisms one's using the
tutor and one's using the prefect
aircraft
and it didn't make sense and a sense
certainly didn't understand
you've got pilots who are going to end
up flying you know going on the same
rotary course
the the the the the the Prelude was very
very different indeed is that something
you could please look at because that
didn't make sense again two separate
contracts for something they that both
could be you know those cost to be saved
there yeah so Simplicity of a course not
they're not separate contracts but
there's a different philosophy between
the two this has been an issue for some
years and we will be looking at again
when I take over right okay some years
you say so so when when this was a so if
you go back uh kind of 10 years there
was a debate about whether you could go
you could go straight to rotoru in
Italian and do any and not do any fixed
Wing at all and the Army in the Navy
were Keen to keep some fixed Wing in
which is the tutor flying the air force
streams people through Elementary flying
train it takes people through Elementary
flying training and then streams them at
the end of that streaming means decide
based on your capacity and capability
whether you're gonna go fastjet
multi-engine or rotary wink so everybody
is captured but where if you join the
Army you're not going to fly anything
other than rotary Wing Navy and applying
fast yet so that's the bit that we just
need to work work through and I think
Ascent is right is that's that's worthy
of looking at again now that system has
stabilized well now that you're you are
where you are I'm proud after all these
years it's now being looked at that's
right it's been looked at before it's
just the Army Navy made the decision
that they did I think we should go back
and review that again okay wow thank you
look there were problems with Hawk
availability long before we had the
issue of the older engine we've had poor
availability on the whole for a number
of years at Valley and that's one of the
reasons we've had such bad back clocks a
very senior person is bae he once told
me
that quote the problem with the mfts
contract is it's so complicated no one's
in charge
and one of the features of the contract
is whenever anything goes wrong everyone
blames everyone else
that's true isn't it so to go back to
your first point about Hawk availability
ahead of the current engine issue the
hawk availability had recovered
have been a recovery program put in
place and it was far it's far improved
on where it was
um from the reference you previously
made in terms of managing the different
interfaces as whilst I agree with you
that the more interfaces makes things
more complicated that was one of the
reasons why we went uh and we did the
hawk uh contract
um react because we wanted to simplify
the number of interfaces but the
relationship between
hawk in terms of bae management and
Ascent is much improved that was one of
the early problems that we had with mfts
it is now much more a single Enterprise
and they are working incredibly well
together so whilst I take your point
about the more number of interfaces
makes it less efficient and effective
what I would say is that as a as a
single Enterprise it is far better than
it was
and that was one of the initial problems
that we overcome it's not what the stats
we were showing yesterday are bearing
out at you've only got so many
hours of availability in so many hawks
on any given day and there are several
problems one is a number of those slots
are taken by Foreign Pilots
a number of those slots are taken by RAF
Pilots that are doing refresher training
because they've had to wait so long that
they couldn't get onto an ocu so they've
had to come back and do more slots to be
current
and because of these problems now with
even worse with the hawk quite a few of
those RAF Pilots are now being trained
abroad
so we've got foreign Pilots being
trained in the UK and UK Pilots being
trained abroad and when we asked does
the taxpayer get any money back for this
we were told no because of the way the
contract is written it really is a very
very poor contract isn't it
so there's a whole bunch of things
wrapped up in that let me see if I can
separate them out in essence so rich
that's the problem everything's wrapped
up with everything else no what you
describe is Raptor I mean it's
interesting that ba system should tell
you that everybody looks everybody else
because beer systems are accountable and
responsible for delivering the
availability of of Hawk and that's where
we have had some significant problems
The Who
would you mean in terms of were they
responsible to so they so they are they
are responsible to to the to the mod and
you're then responsible to ascent and
then Ascend to them responsible to you
and so they are responsible actually
that's how it works isn't it so they are
responsible to us and we then provide
the availability in to Ascent there are
two contracts one would be a systems it
is it is government furnished equipment
and we we provide we provide that
availability so in response to the
chairman very good question why was Hawk
made an exception in the first place so
the answer to that is I don't know I
feel I will go back I will go back to be
helpful to to no no I will go back and
provide you with an answer because just
quickly when cows was here last time you
were here at Sir Richard
he gave us numbers of Pilots that
graduated in the last few years and told
us that quotes it was already fixed and
then I'll choose my words carefully when
we threw some pqs at him with the actual
statistics he admitted that he misspoke
so it's not fixed yet is it your
argument would be it's being fixed but
it's not true to say that it's fixed yet
is it so if we get on to the it you're
talking about so in terms of the the
element that goes from elementary flying
training through to the points at which
you get to uh hawk or to an ocu that is
performing much much better it's not
completely fixed we've still got too
many people in the system and the holds
are too long but that's coming down
really uh rapidly and as I said by
middle of next year we'll see certainly
we're already seeing improvements if
that's actually true why are we having
to do some of this training abroad so
hold on right I've just gone on to Hawk
okay it's the hawk training that we're
doing abroad and the whole training
we're doing abroad is for two reasons
one is because the availability of Hawk
associated with the engine is less than
it should be and secondly because we've
got we've got people in the system
waiting
and we're opening up slots on the
operational conversion unit why wouldn't
we put them through overseas training
we've got a long history of having uh
having done that and currently we're
planning on around 27 UK Pilots to be
trained uh on uh fastjets overseas ahead
of the operational conversion unit we're
not sure whether we need all that many
because of we think the hawk will
recover faster but we're not going to
reduce that number so that we've we
um hedge against further problems with
the Hawk Engine
last question
your predecessor as cows or still cows
was famously given one quotes one job by
Ben Wallace which was to fix the
military fine training system with no
disrespect to you but the description
we've had this afternoon it's not
convince this committee it's fixed it
might be getting better but fixed I
think he's going too far have you been
given a similar instruction my secretary
of state I have not yet had any specific
direction from the defense secretary but
I anticipate that flying training is
going to be a key because of whatever he
gives me if I might just say just on
this point about is it ever fixed one of
the things I would say drawn on 30 years
of experience but particularly over the
last 10 15 is that flying training is
complicated it's complex and complicated
it's affected by a whole bunch of
external factors that we don't
necessarily have control over whether
that's government decisions whether
that's the act the pipe the commercial
sector and loss of Pilots what I do know
is if you take your eye off it for a
moment it can get out of the tolerances
that you set so I can assure you Mr
Francois and I'll certainly assure the
secretary of state that me and the team
will be keeping a close eye on this all
through my period as well
please yeah I put the clarification in
terms of recovery so we for the engine
we have a recovery profile okay to
return the aircraft to the 50
availability that we need in terms of
engines and aircraft by the end of this
year so we are currently at at a 13
engines of which we've got effectively
11 aircraft that will return by
September
218 we then Flatline and then at the
back end of next year when we get the
components that we need for the front of
the engine that will then recover so we
are back to where we need to be at the
beginning of 2025 that is a plan it's
been managed closely it has been managed
by Rolls-Royce and saffron together and
we have full transparency on the on
those parts that are in the supply chain
and we'll fix this problem
uh yeah so you might say it'll be fixed
then but it's not fixed now
in terms of that element Hawk
availability due to the engine
absolutely right okay so that's that's
under engine availability only Minister
one for you um there's something called
the air crew pipeline Steering group
um which is quite fundamental talking
about bringing people together
um I could we recommend that you sit on
this or attend it once you're shaking
your head already because just
familiarize yourself with this because
the the the ascent flying training
limited for example are not represented
on there just the point came up is the
left hand of the right hand is being
able to find out ways that you can fix
these these aspects such as this idea
that Hawk is slid across the table away
from the med contract I think apparently
it's this group that we determined that
perhaps would be the the vehicle for
that to happen the second one is just to
do with a study that Gavin Robinson did
recently on diplomacy and soft power
because getting
um uh International students through the
pilot training scheme is one of the
great things that we can do people will
enjoy will appreciate will you know ask
to come to the UK to complete their
flying training from across the world we
need to have availability to make that
happen but as Mark was implying it can't
be to the detriment of us then having to
send our own Pilots abroad that simply
doesn't make sense the Thursday war game
sir you'll be familiar with that is
another great opportunity of us showing
that we provide that Sandhurst driven
them all these things are providing the
international students
you mentioned you're the head of the U.S
Air Force in um Europe I don't know when
you may have come across each other at
Miramar and you'd start off your career
I don't know you've developed their
friendships and that's important and
that's where us sharing these these
training schools are very important well
I just just had a little bit of color
for my uh chairman sir is uh suited Mr
Francois point we we do get paid
um if we train overseas students yes um
so the Qatar is part of that overall
deal with 12 Squadron what I say is Dr
Khaled who is the defense minister for
uh in in Qatar was went through Flight
Training and Hawk training at the end of
the typhoon and in the 1980s typhoon
F-15 and Raphael he tells me
um and I am convinced that the his
experience and positive experiences
played a part in in the decision making
yeah he flew the typhoon and then he
appreciated that and that helped with
the deal so absolutely right because of
the challenges we have right now what
we've negotiated with and it's helpfully
come position with our our allies where
we really reduce down the number of
international students going through the
system to ensure that we can prioritize
British students and as the availability
recovers that will change over time and
we will get the benefits that uh Mr
Robinson describes in his report okay
because you asked me I think on these
particular points Mr and um uh I mean
the I think the first and most important
thing to say is
um obviously the operational side of
training is very much responsibility of
the uh senior leadership but you know
say as you said a huge priority from
secretary's point of view
um and for me it's a it's it's clearly
this is about a very personal issue the
idea of people aspiring to join the Air
Force and having these long Waits or
being on hold or whatever you want to
call it we don't want that to be of an
undue length for reasons that we could
control I want to be absolutely clear on
that so the first thing I asked in terms
of you know the overall picture
and terrible there's a lot of you know
technical speak in this world but
there's this phrase of getting back to
Optimal because it's essentially a
pipeline you're getting back to the
point where you've got an optimal
balance between people on hold waiting
Etc so on the fast Jets next march
multi-engine next march and rotary the
following March so that's the the
longest so it is improving that's what
we mean by improving as I understand it
um on the point about the study which I
I am so I wasn't aware of but it sounds
a really really interesting to me sorry
tomorrow but but I'm aware of it now you
can give you embargo copy it sounds
extremely logical I don't have an
example from flight all I can say is
when I went to cop as a treasurements I
meant the president of Egypt and what
sorry the finances for Egypt what made
him so positive about us was the fact he
studied at a UK University it's the same
principle yeah Okay Kevin
turn to what I don't think is one of
your finest hours which is the purchase
of five Airbus h135 helicopters
you bought five of them brand new and
then mothballed them
why
um
so uh as I understand they're in what we
call Storage mothball yeah well I've
been used
so um
I'm speaking from my previous role this
is not an Air Force procurement it
wasn't it doesn't meet an Air Force
requirements
um why did we buy at them because at the
time there was a requirement and a
policy review removed that requirement
what was it I don't think I can talk
about that in public Mr James I'm sorry
because of because of the the nature of
the task that they were due to undertake
but that requirement has been withdrawn
and as I understand it from talking to
the team the other day the options for
what happens to those five aircraft
whether we sell them use them in a
different role or exchange them in some
some way are being considered and that's
due to be decided on in the next few
weeks I understand
purposes and then they're not being used
it's not as straightforward as that but
I will yeah well no I mean the I mean
how much did it cost them this to buy
five
I don't know off the top of my head I'm
sorry well I mean there's two things
isn't there I mean yeah there's the cost
to buying them what the spares package
and thrill life support was going to be
at them so I think I think we'd be
interested to know what it is and also
the ongoing cost of actually
so I mean the longer you have them I
mean I do remember the bad days in fact
you can uh Chief Marshal and we had the
Chinook stored for God knows how many
years
um so I mean I think it would be we'd
like that information about uh and any
information you give about look at how
much we can write to you about that
there are some sensitivities but I will
look at that well I don't think it is
sensitivity no well there is I
understand and yeah I'm quite happy to
accept as a capability that we can't
share was what it was purchased I think
the basic thing is about cost and the
you know and what it's costing it I
think is is that's not sensitive that's
a fair question and what the timelines
are going to be to actually why
what are you going to do with them
because like I say we don't really want
been eight years time final still
there's still an Hangar somewhere do we
that's a good point I will
it's that sorry that very quick at that
point can I just check one thing just
it's just in terms I don't I accept the
reason why you can't perhaps go into the
tasking was that because of the
decision a political Edition on costs or
was it a uh capable as an operational
requirement decision made by ministers
yeah based on advice
cried
so we can't say no we can't say any more
than that
no I'm just trying to get whose decision
it was I saw whether it was a like the
uh it's on uh E7 or whether it was like
based on cost at all I will try and get
as information to the committee I'm just
trying to understand what it's not about
cost but it's actually like you're
saying that there was an operational
decision I think it'll be helpful for us
even if it was a private briefing if you
were able to give us some better
understanding of that to buy five
purchase five helicopters and then to to
mothball them
still taxpayers money that needs to be
accounted for I'll take advice on the
best way well I think we should be clear
that we shouldn't conflate
um being understandably census uh
answers only sensitivity with
embarrassment they're not one in the
same thing
good well just like on that point
cosplay very quickly
edges Marshall you're adamant about the
720 million saving on the E7 we are
unconvinced
could you send us in writing within a
week a detailed breakdown of how that
720 million is calculated so that we can
scrutinize it please
um I will defer to the minister on uh
that but I would imagine that uh we'll
I'm sure the minister will be happy to
write it'd be what is commercially
sensitive but okay yes sorry yes yes we
we will respond
good Minister well done for surviving
your your first uh defensive committee
inquiry but really grateful for your
kindness your your openness
um and your time today along with uh air
Chief Marshall Sir Richard Knighton and
also vice admiral Richard Thompson
thanks very much indeed uh for your time
today thank you to the Clarks and to the
staff and to committee members that
brings our evidence session to a
conclusion order order